at the time when I was recording it I
almost listen back and hear these lyrics
as a cry for help
demi lovato raw candid and honest about
making her musical comeback and you kind
of listen back to it you kind of think
how did nobody listen to the song and
think let's help this girl look you know
it and say the 27 year old singer was
interviewed for new music daily with
Zane Lowe on Apple musics beats one
during their chat Demi opened up about
performing her new song anyone at the
2020 Grammy Awards it's taken me a long
time to be able to even get this far in
which is performing a song that's so
vulnerable to me
Demi said the track became very special
to her in 2018 when she was hospitalized
after a drug overdose it was about a
week after I had been in the hospital
and I was finally like awake and and I
just remember hearing back the songs I
had just recorded and thinking if
there's ever a moment where I get to
come back from this I want to sing this
song this singer reflected on that low
point in her life and she said she's
still a work-in-progress when it comes
to choosing the people in her inner
circle you learn for your entire life
red flags things to look for unless
you're like a hundred years old with a
bunch of life experience you're never
gonna know right away who's good for you
and who's not you know sometimes you get
fooled sometimes you get into
relationships that you think are healthy
and then you realize wow that actually
was a holiday at all moving forward the
future is brighter than bright for Demi
not only will she take the stage at the
Grammys she's also gonna sing the
national anthem at the Super Bowl and
she's working hard on music but on a
personal note Demi has one specific goal
in mind at some point in this decade I
want to start a family I don't even know
if I see it with a man or a woman but I
would love to start doing more things
that make me happy and
which worried less about success et has
spoken with Demi many times about her
commitment to healthy living there's a
drive that I have to stay sober because
I know that my life depends on it I see
a therapist two days a week I reach out
to people that whenever I'm struggling
with something I you know I work out I
eat clean I have a healthy support
system around me sometimes say I just
look back and I'm just grateful to be
alive you know I do kind of like sit
there and think well I'm so glad that I
got sober and I'm able to help you
[Music]